because i think that a lot of people
know you know what a producer does on a
movie set and they know what a director
does and screenwriter and all these
different things
but often the people that are the
executives behind the scenes at the
studios who are
championing these films to get made
often
you know there's no light there's
there's no limelight on these people
and i actually want to jump backwards
and sort of talk about what exactly did
you do
at disney to help get certain movies
made how did that all work
um well that's a really good really good
question i wasn't uh i wasn't
prepared for that i think that the
the way to think about it is there's a
lot of different levels inside the
company obviously there's sort of where
the buck stops at the chairman of the
studio
but then there's a lot of layers
underneath from the from sort of
ground level creative executive whose
job it is to go out and shake the trees
find ideas find articles find books find
scripts find new writers new filmmakers
and bring those in into the system
and a lot of that is based on that work
for me was always based on
is it something that speaks to me is it
something that i like or understand or
find exciting
is it something i find intriguing is
this a filmmaker that makes me feel
something and how do i bring them
into the into the system then as you
move higher up the
up the ladder it becomes about how do
you how do you package these movies and
how do you build
how do you ultimately convince the
company to make an investment
in the movie so getting the script to a
certain place
getting certain attachments whether it's
directors or actors
finding a way to craft the budget in a
way that gives them confidence
and and figuring out how to build a
consensus inside the company
to help you uh make the case that that's
a movie to invest in and make
at the next level up there's sort of the
more theoretical space
where you sit back and you look at the
investment portfolio for the studio you
look at what is the amount of investment
that that company is going to make in
in this case feature films and
try to plan out how you think you can
get the best return based on that almost
like a
hedge fund or an investment account so
uh when i was involved in that the
landscape
looked very different and you could
release a 10
15 million dollar comedy on a weekend
and and
have a really good return um
now there's certain types of films that
i think just don't really work
theatrically anymore
since streaming so we would look at it
as a breakdown of like okay you want to
do
two big jerry bruckheimer movies every
year you want to do a big
adam sandler comedy you want to do uh
a series of you want to do a wes
anderson movie
you want to do a night shyamalan movie
so you build out
this sort of slate of different price
points and different audiences that
you're targeting and then
um sort of create that format that
investment format
that then your executives who are
creating projects and packages
you can then start to fit those in into
the overall strategy
when you were um working on these
projects at disney
how much were was the studio looking at
other studios to see what they're
releasing
um and you know maybe the budgets
they're spending and the release dates
they have and how much is it sort of
like
well we can only really judge what we're
gonna do
and you can't really look at what
everyone else is doing because
you never know well i think there's a
there's a balance in that i think you
you look at what other studios are doing
you don't necessarily take that as your
north star your guide but you
it informs the decisions that you can
make so
if they're making a certain type of film
that
is not working that's not getting any
box office that nobody really wants to
see
well that sort of makes you re-evaluate
projects that you might have
in that area but it's not definitive
because they might have just made
a poor choice on which movie to pack
they might have had a bad uh
campaign so it doesn't you know you're
always trying to like
feed that information into the machine
uh and then make your own decisions when
it came to development there certainly
were jokes about people
that whatever number one at the box
office was
you could be sure that the next week uh
some other studio is going to buy that's
you know another project just like it
that was always
uh i did not ascribe to that i always
thought
if one type of movie worked in
spectacular fashion the worst time to
try to buy one and put it together was
immediately in the aftermath
and that what was a more effective
strategy was to try to find things that
were original and different
but still you felt like had a place in
the marketplace that there was still a
fan base to service
what years were you doing that at disney
uh i was at disney from 1995
until 2012.
right and so you rose the ranks through
those years yeah
what when you think back on that time uh
i know there must have been numerous
projects
that came close to going you couldn't
get a star with scheduling
couldn't get a director whatever the
reason is it couldn't work um
what are some of the examples if you
don't mind sharing of projects that you
really wanted to get off the ground uh
but couldn't
for whatever reason uh
there was a project um which jerry
bruckheimer
called uh unnatural history which was
a it was ultimately didn't go into
production because night at the museum
got greenlit and happened faster than we
were able to package the movie
and we had a good ver we had a really
good script i think
and i thought it was a lot of fun uh
but it was just it was bad timing and
then by the time we had sorted out a
couple of issues that needed to be
figured out
we had we've sort of lost the race but
it was uh it was a museum that came to
life but it
wasn't um it wasn't teddy roosevelt
coming back from the dead it was the
animation it was
things became animated in the museum so
tyrannosaurus rex
the skeleton of the tyrannosaurus rex
was chasing you around
so um that was just a big fun
movie that i thought could have been the
launch of a franchise
uh i know you guys spoke to jerry about
national treasure three a while back
believe me i bring it up with him every
single time i talk to him
uh i i tried my damnedest to get
national treasure three up i
i love those movies i worked on those
from from sort of inception
and believe me i was going to bring this
up i have to ask you with national
treasure
so to me i i think one and please
correct me if i'm wrong on this but
my gut feeling is that one of the
reasons national treasure three didn't
go
is that when the first one was made
hollywood was a completely different
beast
where there was a lot more first dollar
gross a lot more producers getting money
like the economic system
that's sure that that is for sure
producers do not make what they used to
right so what i'm saying what i'm saying
though with national treasure is
you know back then when nick cage did it
he was getting a lot more money
a lot more there was a lot more money
being pulled
in terms of like say the movie made 100
million dollars maybe
30 million was going to people before
the studio saw anything i'm just
guessing at this right
so my question is is one of the reasons
national treasure 3 never got made
is because it was almost too expensive
to make the movie
because of old production deals no
although that's a
that is a concern anytime you do a
sequel particularly sequel that has
historical first dollar grows out um
there's always a way to work around
those deals
it never got to that um on national
treasure three when i was around
i i think that part of what happened and
this is a more
sort of uh uh insider nuance take on it
to be honest um
what i felt happen is even though the
movies themselves were extremely
successful
and had really a really strong fan base
it's it's it's a movie that gets brought
up
all the time particularly the first one
unfortunately the company was never able
to capitalize on it
as a franchise it really operated in the
market more as a movie with a sequel
and national treasure 3 would have been
another sequel
they never found a way to integrate it
into the parks it never caught on as
driving even though there were a lot of
consumer products books and things like
that
it never really caught on as as an
independent franchise and i think that
makes the numbers look different it
makes the
it makes it harder to get a company like
disney to focus resources on something
when they can go make toy story or go
buy a
cruise ship um and if
if the company itself had been really
excited about moving forward with it and
thought that they could
could blow it out um we would have found
a way to make the deals
yeah so basically you're saying if
national people had bought national
treasure action figures
national treasure 3. uh i think it's
more
if we had i think today there is
something
there's some really interesting stuff
that you could have
moved national treasure out right so
i'll give you an example of like why i
love that
movie not just from a from an
entertainment standpoint
but we shot at the national archives
which was not easy
to pull off the production team tore
their hair out trying to
get the approvals through the federal
government and all of that stuff
then the year after the movie came out
attendance at the national archives went
up 400
and it stayed high and it has continued
to stay at an elevated level since that
movie came out
and i loved that the number of friends
of mine the number of family members who
came and said you know what my kid won't
stop talking about american history
and he's reading all these books and now
i've got to read these books so that i
don't look stupid in front of my kid
i thought that was like one of the
greatest things that ever happened and
the ben gates character
the reason i love the ben gates
character is because his super powers
that he cares and that he's smart
and it's not he's not the strongest guy
he's not pulling out a gun he's not
kicking somebody's ass
he's using his intelligence and his sort
of lack of cynicism to win the day
and and i love that about him and i
think that's um
it's harder to do but i thought it paid
off so
i really think that nowadays um
with the technology with the smartphones
all that there's a way to take that fun
and move it out into the digital space
and to
whether it's location based game play or
or things like pokemon go or whatever
that you could have done to really make
it a bigger
uh cultural uh
had to have it have a bigger cultural
impact than it did that said i know
jerry keeps working
on stuff and i know that there's a lot
of interest in a series
and in a another feature and i think
it's ripe to
sort of reinvent i again i've
interviewed him
what every time i've interviewed him for
like 10 years that's my main question
um but he did give me you know what's
interesting about jerry is that he never
gives me a scoop he
he's so good on his talking
and when i was talking to him last time
he actually dropped how they were
developing it for disney plus
as a national treasure series and as he
said it i'm like
i actually think no one knows this but i
don't want to say anything
enough you know after i'm like oh wow he
actually gave me a really good story
thank you yeah make it up yeah i mean
he's been doing the he's been doing
press for a long time
i couldn't believe it it was the first
time in you know all my years of talking
to him that i got something that was
you know an actual breakout story like
that you know
uh but you know what anyway but jumping
jumping back so
i want to talk about enchanted for a
second uh what
you worked on um and so i'm curious it's
now i guess
gonna finally get a sequel what the f
took so long
since like 2007 or whatever it was to
get a sequel to that movie which seems
so in the disney wheelhouse
yeah i don't even know how to answer
that one
um there was a there was a really good
idea for a sequel
um and at the time uh all of the people
involved in this decision have have long
since left the studio
but there wasn't a lot of passion uh to
revisit the story even though
it performed incredibly well and it was
beloved
and it was right in the wheelhouse and
it was a unique
ip building project as opposed to
it wasn't expanding ip it was creating
its own new ip
which i continue to think is very
important
it just it just couldn't get over the
hump but now the team at disney i think
sees it with a little clearer vision and
is is
taking advantage of uh of a great
opportunity so what you're saying is you
tried to get it off the ground
oh my god did i try so hard i still feel
badly there's there's a song there's a
couple of songs that
uh we hadn't written but we knew
the shape of the song and where they
would fit and
uh breaks my heart that we never got to
do them then we never got to him but
i'll tell you
barry josephson has been uh
indefatigable in the pursuit of that
movie
like he's been working on it and never
gives up
so that's a that's a good good producer
uh you worked with michael bay on
armageddon and pearl harbor
yeah yeah um michael is an interesting
guy
i've watched him on set i've interviewed
him
uh but you know when he was making
armageddon in pearl harbor that's
maybe a different michael bay because
it's you know 20 years ago
or whatever it was um what was it like
making those movies with him
oh i i i loved it the first
movie that i worked on uh when i started
was the rock
and i didn't have much i ran dailies on
it basically and
took care of you know making sure the
paperwork went where it was supposed to
go but
so i would sit part of my job was i
would sit every day with reels of film
and watch every take and every setup
that michael bay shot and he shoots a
lot of film
even then it was a lot of footage i mean
he gets that kodak million dollar
million foot jacket back when back when
we shot on film like every movie
and um it was kind of like going to film
school because i was always a big fan
of uh of the hong kong movies
in you know finding dvd or blu-rays
not blue we're talking about laser discs
and going and hunting down laser discs
in film school and watching all this
great stuff
and um and so i was watching
and his visual styling his ability to
tell story
inside of action is is pretty amazing
and i remember that there would be
people coming in
very experienced film executives both on
the production and the creative side
who would be watching dailies and just
say like he doesn't know what he's doing
like it's a disaster he just doesn't
know how to how to shoot a scene
and the whole time i'm going like uh no
i think this guy's crushing it right now
i mean
and um we would get to the test
screening we cut see it cut together
and and it was really visceral and
really exciting and really fun
um he is an interesting
guy to work with he's super intense i
think would be a way to say it
um one of the things that i have always
liked and respected about michael
is that he he doesn't stop
it's not like he's uh you know taking a
break in the trailer and
uh you know playing video games while
the crew's out working
he'll jump on a camera and operate he'll
jump in the helicopter and
you know if he could fly it he would he
never stops
working when he's on set and i think
that's
a real tribute to his passion
i saw him on a on the transformers
set forget with the one with the first
mark wahlberg one
and he had his own he had his camera um
in the middle of the action um with
explosions going on with like five other
camera people and he is right there in
it
trying to get a shot and uh one of the
guns and one of the soldiers
wasn't working right and he was not
happy after that take because it was an
expensive take
and uh so i got i got to see a full bay
out
and then a um i got to see a lot that
day
it was great you know it was a full full
run of emotions yeah one of the things
that i think you know
he's uh he's a favorite whipping boy of
the press and people like to talk
uh talk smack about michael all the time
uh
but i will say if you watch his
imitators
and then go back and watch what he does
it's so it's so clear that
the things that he is great at he's
better than
i mean he's better than almost anybody
working
and and i think that's i get excited
i was super excited to see um
any any action sequence that he shot i
feel like every trailer
i'm always excited i don't always love
the movies but i'm
always excited by the look and the feel
and i think he's
we see the people that try to do bay but
aren't him i think you see
the the brilliance and the madness
listen i i think he is a very unique
filmmaker
and when he strikes gold he strikes
platinum
it's fantastic but you know i will admit
even as a huge fan he doesn't always
strike gold
um but i still am very excited to see
anything he'll make
yeah you can't can't not it's a it's a
thing
and by the way you know there's there's
uh he's not the only filmmaker working
so for people that don't like him like
there's lots of other movies go watch
those completely um
jumping into your time with tony scott
on deja vu um
what was that like i loved town i i
loved
i i miss tony a lot and um
uh i was always we had developed a movie
together
that unfortunately didn't go called take
down going back to your early
earlier question which was a sort of uh
sort of a gritty uh a gritty thriller
that uh that tony had come on board to
that was that was a really great
really fun movie um
he's just you know he's a wonderful guy
and he
creates sequences that i think just have
a feeling and an energy that that no one
else has
and and i know that you know i'm
probably getting trouble for saying it
but i know that michael
uh speaking of bae like was always
watching tony's stuff
and going like okay how do i bet how do
i beat that
you know that there's a like okay you've
managed to do that i'll show you i can
do
i can do better and uh and i i just love
tony he's a he's
very sweet he was a very sweet man uh
also one of the hardest working people
i've ever seen like
he was all go no quit so uh i was very
fortunate to
to get to to actually make a movie with
him
yeah what you mentioned this takedown
how close did that come to getting made
pretty close we had a budget we had a
script we had a we had a lead actor and
we had our director
and uh it all sort of fell apart over
that one did fall apart over deal stuff
i can't remember how how it what the
final nail in the coffin was
but i can still think there's like two
or three scenes in that movie that i
still really
that i still think about it's
interesting because like a project like
that let's use that as an example you
have a script everyone likes
does it ever when you guys are working
on other projects does it ever come up
like
okay we need a good action set piece in
this film none of these are that good
what about that script that we're not
making can we take that set piece
yeah uh i've never i've never done that
because i always feel like
that's somebody else's set piece it's
something somebody else wrote that
somebody else created
um and i've never found one that i can't
think
of anything where it's like okay that's
the
oh the perfect fix to this is to you
know
take the animal cracker scene from
armageddon and put it in this movie
because they're always so uh sort of the
best ones are such a
piece of the thing that they are part of
um
now i i think that that's sort of uh in
a lot of ways uh
i would see it as a violation of the
trust of the people i work with
or if it's a writer that came up with it
or director to move it to something else
unless it was theirs did you have a
comedy writer we had to say we had the
same
set piece in two perhaps three different
scripts that we worked on together
it got cut from the first one and we're
like we always really liked it so we put
it in another one
and didn't get made either so i guess
maybe we should have let it go
when you think back on the projects you
made which is a movie
that you really thought oh this is not
gonna work and it ended up
being it really worked and what's a
movie you're like this
is a box office for sure juggernaut
and then it ended up bombing or it ended
up not being what you
hoped it was going to be say let's see
um i always believe they're always going
to work
i think you have to right even if it's
like
this is this is totally uh just to get
through the day and all the pain and
suffering you gotta like
this is gonna work i would say one that
i was
disappointed in the performance of and
uh i thought it should have done better
um was a movie called rain of fire
oh that's i literally was gonna bring
that's my next thing to bring up with
you
that's funny i love it's got a lot of
problems but
uh and it was a painful movie to make at
times but i
i loved that movie and i really really
enjoyed
um working i love i love rob bowman
uh you know christian and matthew were
great it was just
really um i thought it was really cool
and outside the box but
uh we lost a road to perdition by like a
million dollars on opening weekend and i
think the difference between being
number one at the box office and being
number two
uh would have changed the whole
trajectory of the movie
and i gotta tell you man i got when we
were doing
anytime i do press i always get
questions about rain of fire
well that's because of that cast and
also that's one of those movies where if
it comes on cable
late at night i'm [ __ ] because i just
like we'll just start watching
but the other thing is you put a dragon
in a movie
way before cgi was where cgi is now so
it's like you're like effort
we're gonna put a dragon in oh yeah you
know
actually we called her ashley i don't
know i i realized later it's
never mentioned in the movie there's
never a name in the movie but
um i just found
strangely enough i was going through uh
some boxes in my attic a little while
back and i found a bunch of stuff
from uh from raina fire it was a walk
down memory lane
yeah i didn't realize you came out the
same weekend as a
road to perdition that's not good no and
uh
and uh bob and harvey
were nice enough to drop halloween h2o
on the same weekend which is literally
what cost us the number one slot
against road to perdition and they did
it intentionally
because they're super nice guys oh i've
heard that actually
yeah yes i remember losing my temper
about
because they moved it and they moved it
up or moved it back a couple of weeks
and it was just a petty act of you know
aggression against
their owner and uh
it just angered me so much that i
i think i got in trouble in a staff
meeting for um
for for railing about how how horrible
they
are a little too loudly and not even
knowing how truly truly truly horrible
they are
obviously during this pandemic i'm
assuming you're still working you're
still working on things
even though you're just working from
home so what do you have bubbling up in
terms of uh
projects we do television and film
um one of the things that we we started
experimenting with because we're
not able to go shoot anything um we
launched a
family focused podcast called kid pod
theater which has been
really fun we've gotten we do a little
series
six part series about an hour and a half
two hour long in total and we try things
out and it's
relatively inexpensive to do and it's
actually really fun so we get
we have one with angela kinsey from the
office and
uh we just record it and have a good
time and try some stuff out
um so we've been doing that some of that
may ultimately translate into
series or feature projects but really
it's just because we needed to go make
something
and we get edgy if we don't if we're not
making something new
so that was really fun uh we have we
have a
couple of projects in development with
disney television studios right now some
network and some streaming
and um we're waiting to see when
uh when the town opens up again because
we've got a couple of smaller movies
that we'd like to try to put together
relatively quickly yeah it's interesting
because um
everyone i've spoken to the challenge is
that uh so many people's projects
had to be you know you hit pause in
march when everything was shut down
so scheduling for people right now from
what i'm understanding is um
a whole other level because you know
well and who's you know just that time
especially for a lot of really in demand
talent there's
always you know they're always trying to
so i can do
this broadway show before i go do this
sequel before i go do this movie that's
my passion project whatever and then
everything gets pushed back and it's
like who who gets canceled
um and what are the contractual impacts
of it you know there's all kinds of
stuff and it's just having this
cascading effect through through the
town so
and at the same time all these streamers
in particular they need content
they need new stuff and so they're like
trying to package up
before they know exactly when they can
start shooting again
and so that's creating a whole new rush
so
yeah we found it difficult to
it just takes more work it's not
difficult it just takes more effort to
get any kind of packaging going
and people aren't really sure there's
still a lot of executive changes at a
number of different places there's
structural changes
at a couple of different companies and
they're not necessarily
you know one one of the things that you
you learn as an executive is sometimes
the process dictates the product
and who has creative authority in an
organization is not always immediately
clear um
and if you're constantly changing
reporting structures and you're changing
staff
and you're trying so like you're trying
to weave a project through
the machine and all of a sudden it's
like oh all these goal posts
yeah we didn't just move we stopped
playing football so now
your your goal is to get a basket so
it's like
everything can change and since there's
so much sort of
uh volatility
uh in all of these big media companies
right now and there's so many business
models that are changing i think it's
it's complicated 100 i'm also curious
what's going to happen with all the
streaming
from netflix to amazon to you name it
because all of them have
product through the end of the year with
no drama
because they shoot so far ahead and
because they have to
dub and translate and get it all ready
so they're all set till christmas early
next year maybe they can push a little
bit
but once you get to february march of
next year they don't have product
because they're going to be watching it
again they're going to be rushing
yes yeah i think you know and then look
at it
it's always doable right you can always
find a way
productions i always think of uh
productions as
problem-solving machines it's like okay
you want to put a camera where
okay let's figure out how to do that you
want to uh
you want to shoot on the moon okay it's
just a just a question of time and money
we can
we'll do it tom cruise can go shoot at
the space station it's just time and
money
um for
and we see you know the network
production cycle is very fast and they
can get
a huge volume of material up and on air
very quickly
it's just whether that process
you know it's a very regimented process
that networks had in order to make that
business model work
so the streamers can can get that
product in that timeline
but it's just whether they're you know
geared up to
to think that way sure i i foresee
a lot more if they're not able to start
filming soon um or
you know there's a lot of hiccups i i
see a lot more international shows
that may be popular in another country
getting acquired and pushing those out
in america
because it's new content look at cbs now
taking discovery
off of cbs all access and putting it on
the network
yeah well and i also think you'll see
unscripted stuff which can just get
turned around a lot faster
you know both netflix and amazon are
doing uh really cool stuff
amazon in particular is doing great
unscripted stuff that's big and a venti
and you know it's it's not cheap but
it's
relatively quick to get to air so thank
you so much and um
uh have a great day okay thanks steven
talk to you soon